[Music]
Kal Shanahan was the offensive
coordinator in Washington when Kirk
Cousins arrived as a first-round pick
and the backup slash safety plan behind
Robert Griffin the third who was the
second overall pick in that same drive
Cousins ends up becoming the starter
Shanahan believes in cousins there was a
belief when Shanahan became the head
coach of the 49ers that he would try to
get cousins if and when cousins became a
free agent Jimmy Garoppolo trade got in
the way Chris and now that we are
getting farther along the lifecycle of
the Jimmy Garoppolo contract and I think
this is a big year for Garoppolo and
it's only a 4.2 million dollar cap
charge if they would move on from him
after this season and with Kirk Cousins
I think in an upper out year for the
Vikings yeah where he's gonna earn an
extension beyond 2020 or the Vikings
gonna be saying how can we dump the
final year of his contract which happens
to be fully guaranteed at 29 million
plus in compensation and a 31 million
dollar cap charge we've mentioned this a
couple of times but it bears repeating
Kyle Shanahan if he could find a way to
swap out Garoppolo for cousins after
this season if the Vikings want to move
on if Shanahan wants to move on for
Garoppolo and he finally gets to bring
this all together and thread that needle
you know him is that something that he
would would rule out is it something
that he would rule in I I don't think
it's crazy Mike I don't think you know
this thought or this theory I don't
think it's crazy you know one you know
to to comment on what you said really to
start the segment about you know yes it
seemed like there was a lot of talk out
there about you know Kyle Shanahan was
gonna try to get Kirk Cousins to the San
Francisco 49ers and all that I think
that's very real I think that's what the
49ers and the draft of true Biscay
deshaun Watson Patrick mahomes they
didn't really get into the quarterback
conversation the year they took Solomon
Thomas because I think there was a
thought that they would get Kirk Cousins
and that following year free agency and
he'd be part of their football team
things changed whatever they got off to
a really bad start their own I know and
10 and I think they felt like that man
we need to get somebody in here right
now that we know we can get here and not
have to bid with and free agency and
that's where they got Jimmy Garoppolo
but I would not you know I do
we were getting towards the edge of the
territory at the end of the shelf-life
of this minute Minnesota football team -
like what you're saying if things didn't
work out this year and they went seven
and nine and six and ten or eight and
eight and missed the playoffs do they
abandon ship and kind of restart and
retool their team how they do that there
and yes at the 49ers underperform you
know could I see them going after a Kirk
Cousins certainly Mike I really could I
could see it happening you know I just
think and I'm gonna throw this in there
Mike - this might be a surprise to you
the Rams
Sean McVeigh Jared Goff I'll throw that
into the convo - I know you've thrown
out that theory the last few weeks and I
don't think it's that crazy either you
know just with my history of knowing
Sean McVeigh Kyle Shanahan I think
there's a great respect factor for Kirk
Cousins and how he executed their
offense and how he was on top of his
game mentally on a day-by-day basis that
was so impressive to them that I do
think there's a lot of respect there
from McVeigh and Shanahan with with Kirk
Cousins
yeah McVeigh was the coordinator in
Washington with Cousins as the starter
and cousins had 40 917 passing yards the
last year that McVeigh was the offensive
coordinator in Washington and I know
that McVeigh has a ton of respect for
him now you said that not me I did I've
got myself into plenty of Jared Goff
predicaments lately but our theory is
and correct me if I'm wrong the idea
that Jared Goff may eventually ask for
so much financially and they're not
talking now they've they've talked about
a timeline for when they will talk but
if Jared Goff makes a demand that is far
and away more than what the Rams want to
pay then you have to look at that
alternative who else is out there
could I get Kirk Cousins if Jared Goff
is looking for 40 million a year and I
could get cousins for 20 20 at 29
million a year is that something that I
consider and look folks these teams they
rip the names off the back of the jersey
all the time and they make decisions in
the best interest of the organization
and I don't think you can rule out
anything at this point especially if
Cousins is available via trade after the
2019 season if the Vikings just decide
he's not the answer and we need to move
on no yes and I mean you know and again
given the history that McVeigh and
Shanahan have with Kirk Cousins and they
were so successful when he was playing
quarterback with them and at the bottom
line here
you know for me and I know not
everything I say is written in stone I
understand that but hey Kirk Cousins is
more talented than Jimmy Garoppolo and
Jared Goff he's just a better
quarterback for my money now Garoppolo I
know we haven't seen a ton of it he
shows glimmers here and there but I
think over the last few years I'm very
comfortable in saying I would rather
have Kirk Cousins than Jared Goff or
Jimmy Garoppolo I just want the record
to be clear you're the one that brought
up Jared Goff I know it's hot meanie
send all night meet me right after this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports